pour ces arbres tout juste coupé le
chemin sera long direction l'asie 500
tonnes de bois sont chargés sur ces
camions depuis une parcelle privée au
détriment de la filière française et
locale
j'allais visiter un lot de chaînes sur
pied à quelques centaines de mètres et
je suis tombé sur ce gros lot de grumes
qui était mis en tas destiné au
chargement dans les conteneurs pour sa
série artisanale
un tel volume de bois représenterait un
mois et demi de travail
en 20 ans jean-pierre mandel est passée
de 27 salariés à seulement 5
il s'inquiète pour l'avenir de son
entreprise et ce qui me chagrine c'est
de voir ben d'autres savoir-faire qui va
partir à l'étranger comme ça le mot
toute cette matière première qui sera
pas transformé dont nous unités je suis
très en colère de chêne français sur
trois partent désormais vers l'asie
ces deux dernières années les prix ont
doublé voire triplé sur certaines
qualités
d'ici à quelques mois les premières
séries ont commencé à disparaître par
manque de matière
les premières syrie mais aussi nos
clients charpentiers menuisiers artisans
qui vont se retrouver en rupture
d'approvisionnement plus de bois plus de
matière les chantiers vont s'arrêter et
le consommateur final ne pourra plus du
tout avoir de bois pour ses projets la
profession réclament un encadrement de
l'exportation des bois français soit
faire des quotas soient taxés à
l'exportation les matières premières
voire même dans un premier temps vu la
situation actuelle
faire un embargo complet c'est à dire
interdire purement et simplement les
exportations la filière représente 450
mille emplois en france dont plus de
2000 entreprises en centre val de loire
des emplois aujourd'hui menacée par les
volumes de bois qui partent en asie